give something special for a day from  Memphis Oh Renee from The Young and the  Restless its Peter Bergmann in your news  it's the Mazda mx-5 miata sports  features of two liter engine six-speed  manual transmission rear wheel drive  plus all other formats and paint fabric  protection  it's the Mazda Miata brand new Mazda  Miata hey Peter what's not up somebody  oh yeah in a Bergman Wow uh why don't  you tell Rene what's going on  you're playing Lucky seven and my car is  for sale for one dollar one dollar and I  happen to have $7 on me right now  come on Peter playing a game called  Lucky seven exactly I'm gonna show you  the first number the price of this Mazda  Miata